you have a big family you got five kids
five children you have five children
which in this day and age a lot of
people like myself and II were like 2
and right you know even more well we did
it right the first two times so we
didn't have to keep trying
I even have Mormons come out up to me
going you got to settle down yeah it's a
lot of kids but you know it's I love it
well here's the crazy thing that's all
fine but you told me recently that you
were living in a two-bedroom yes
apartment yes with five children yes are
you still in and I think we had a
picture yeah let's show that picture
this is you guys yeah that was Webb's
there have a box yeah you keep your
children in a box if they they behave
well enough but get the box P is yours
classic comedy we eventually we had to
move we had you didn't move we had to
downsize we went to a what no we moved
now we I think there's like four
bedrooms now and you know okay yeah
there are so like two for a room and
there's always space for another one
because we're open to it because Jesus
told me to okay this brings up something
I want to mention I mentioned I said
that you have this big show coming up in
Madison Square Garden and we plug that
but you have an even bigger show coming
up no this is this is insane
I am going to be doing stand-up comedy
for Pope Francis this is true
he doesn't know no idea so how did this
happen it's what you know like six
months ago I got an email inviting me to
be at this event in Philadelphia for
Pope Francis and I thought oh this is
nice and you know the Bishop of
Philadelphia and invited me and I was
like oh this is great my wife's very
Catholic she's like a Shiite Catholic so
she was thrilled and so um and then a
couple weeks ago vacated the organizers
came to a show I was doing in Atlantic
City and afterwards they're like so how
long do you want to do and I was like oh
I'm performing and they're like yeah
yeah you're performing in front of the
Pope and I'm like what up does he know
English and they're like no he doesn't
healthy it'll be translated and then
what I realized is that I'm gonna be
performing in front of the Pope and over
a million people outside in Philadelphia
that's most insane
I've ever heard of before and I don't
know you know like I keep thinking
there's gonna be a phone call where
they're gonna be like oh we we just
watched your standup we're changing our
- well first of all how did you get who
else is performing I mean are they
here's there's a Reetha Franklin Wow
okay that's she's honey yeah he's funny
funny yeah yeah yeah uh the Bocelli I
can't remember every everyone's parents
has his CD Andrea Bocelli yeah that guy
he he prefers to be called that guy yeah
like I think it's hosted by a Mark
Wahlberg you know but it's it's wait a
minute why is Mark Wahlberg hosting
because he's gonna kick some ass
it's a Catholic event and I think you
know they picked me because every event
I've heard nothing my phone hasn't rung
once I don't I'm like a super Catholic
Irish Catholic how many cannot you have
- yeah
no but I don't know I mean it's it's
weird I I felt like they asked me
because I was like the only comedian
that admitted they believed in God or
something it's like it's it's very
strange but it's terrifying I don't know
why they haven't called me I could bring
my coffee table books and get up you do
my art do no Arnold impression you're
gonna get a call tomorrow yeah I'm sure
I'm serious from Jesus hey thanks for
watching be sure to click subscribe to
see even more great Conan clips you may
now return to your pirated movies and
creepy Japanese pornography